saviez-vous qu'il existe aux échecs une
ouverture appelée le Gambi Halloween pas
besoin de se déguiser en citrouille pour
la jouer par contre il vaut mieux avoir
le cœur bien accroché puis qu'on envoie
dès le début de la partie à l'assau
d'adversaire un cavalier sans tête pour
lui faire peur voyons ensemble comment
ça marche avec les Blancs on joue E4 E5
cavalier F3 cavalier C6 cavalier C3
cavalier F6 jusque là on a une partie
classique des quatre cavaliers quand la
fièvre de minuit s'emp par du Cavalier
Blanc qui vient se sacrifier en E5 dans
un bon kamikaz les noirs s'enarent avec
plaisir de cette friandise mais avec les
pièces blanches on va jouer D4 pour
chasser la cavalerie adverse s'emparer
d'un centre surpuissant dans la foulée
on va continuer de pousser sortir nos
pièces pour obtenir des compensations
terrifiantes et faire trembler notre
adversaire